I felt like I hadn't seen anything as
cinematically exciting as this for such
a long time and I just love okay this
has been something good for me to do I
mean look I hope they enjoy it I mean
we've done it for the buns you know
there's so many of them then we just
hope that with we honor what it is
thereafter with with with what they
found love of production and we're proud
of it we hope the base would respond to
it you know but I mean it was incredible
he's the best I mean you met him he's
the best yeah they're excellent yeah
yeah Dakota's touch you know she's got
an ass pic your eyes and she's the funny
and Jamie's you know Jamie's Jamie walls
above all privacy I mean any job because
you have to like someone but when you're
in the situations that we had to get
into you know you have to you really
have to kind of like get on with the
person gun so the first day I met her we
just instantly to the bonded and she's
very funny and we make each other laugh
so yeah it's good fun amazing I mean I'm
so proud of them because it took a lot
bravery to do something like this as you
can imagine I think it's incredible I'm
so excited to be here I love Berlin it's
one of my favorite cities I'm so excited
I could never pay for anything better I
mean to be part of the festival's
renowned as this is incredible very
excited it's really crazy and I'm I'm
just trying to take it all in stride and
notice all of it it's really amazing I
can't believe it good adaptation I think
people are going to be really pleasantly
surprised yeah I'm piece of it hope that
they were all been really happy because
I really feel like I honored the book
but I also gave something new for
everyone to so I hope they like it
things we spent quite a lot of time
naked so to me it doesn't feel like that
big a deal I'm not to British a person
so I guess I'm probably a little bit
more comfortable my clothes on than off
like most of us but uh yeah I didn't
and bother me too much it's surreal it
feels like it's happening to somebody
else frankly but I'm very excited my
hurt everyone here will be excited to
see the film as well can't wait for you
guys to see the movie I hope you like it